[Music]
this is where we take videos of famous
people and combine them usually for no
good reason other than
we can okay
first up we've melded kim kardashian and
chris christie
i think i've grown a thick skin over the
years but i mean even
like i love trying to dress for my new
body and having even my clothing line
you know custom make pieces for me
next up tom hanks and zoe deschanel
i don't think you could be an actor and
not want to at some point to be on
broadway
and and challenge those waters
[Applause]
[Music]
john mayer and katy perry
[Applause]
i don't feel like i'm in a celebrity
for me it feels like
something that's very human
what's wrong with its eye
it's got one from the mother oh wow god
oh my god
that's just disturbing
finally miley cyrus and billy ray cyrus
[Music]
my dad had always told me and and he
reminded me son you know it's always
important to
be aware of where you're at and always
be looking forward to where you're going
but most importantly never forget where
you come from
[Applause]